now some people are calling it the real
game of Thrones Saudi Arabia's King
Salman has named his 31 year old son
Mohammed bin Salman as first in line to
the throne at the expense of his older
cousin the question is whether the new
heir will kick-start the economy of the
world's biggest oil producer or drive
the whole region off a cliff he's widely
credited for sweeping reforms to reduce
the kingdom's reliance on oil but US
Defence Minister Mohammed bin Salman has
taken Saudi Arabia to war in Yemen and
into a diplomatic crisis with
neighboring Qatar or joining us from
Beirut is Ben Hubbard Middle East
correspondent for The New York Times so
good evening to you Ben were you
surprised by this well it's one of these
things that's surprising and not
surprising I don't think that many
people who follow Saudi Arabia are very
surprised that it actually happened but
the timing itself was the timing was was
was surprising I mean since this since
Mohammed bin Salman the new Crown Prince
of Saudi Arabia came onto the scene in
the early 2015 before that very few
people had never heard of him his father
became King and then started giving him
new positions and since then it's been a
continuous process of him you know
taking up file after file file portfolio
after portfolio and it's not an
exaggeration now to say that there's
hardly any major important thing
happening in the kingdom that this guy
doesn't have a hand in so it's been
quite widely recognized that we were
heading in this direction but I think
most people expected it to take a bit
longer than it did and so you know when
I woke up this morning and saw the news
I said okay it happened we all know
what's going to happen I just didn't
sort of I wouldn't guessed it would have
happened this soon may see a genuine
moderniser Mohammed bin Salman I mean he
likes to sort of pose us and modernize
it you know he's posed for photographs
of people like Mark Zuckerberg from from
Facebook
is he the real deal well I guess it
depends on how you define moderniser I
mean this is somebody who is very
committed to economic reforms I think
he's got a very ambitious social program
I mean the social program he I think
this is
excuse me somebody from the younger
generation that understands that a lot
of the social restrictions inside the
kingdom very much grate on young people
and that there are many many young
Saudis that wish that they could live a
little bit more like they see their
counterparts in other countries living
and in other Arab countries and so I
think he understands that and I think
he's he has made progress on that front
on the economic front you know that I
think Saudi Arabia has a lot of very
very large structural economic problems
that they have to deal with and he's
laid for you know he's put forth some
proposals on how to do this and now it's
really just a question of waiting and
seeing if they can actually work it out
I mean you have the low oil price which
has taken huge amounts of money out of
the state budget you have a huge
demographic imbalance with many many
young people who are entering the job
market every year and most of them many
many of them are not able to find jobs
and so you really have to sort of remake
the economy they have to move away from
dependence on oil they have to find a
way to employ all these young people and
in order to do that you're going to have
to create a new business culture that in
that very much boosts the part of the
private sector and makes it less
dependent on government funding you're
also have to work on things like
education so that young Saudis coming
out of high school and coming out of
university have the kinds of education
that are going to make them able to do
different kinds of work than their
parents did yeah now you mentioned that
I mean he's had a hand in every pie more
or less something one of those of course
is the war in Yemen which he's largely
prosecute I mean there's not been a non
annoyed success has it and it seemed my
money's been behind the confrontation
with Qatar right I mean he's he and I
think he's I mean that I would say that
the the war in Yemen is definitely the
the I think it's probably the most
dangerous part of his legacy so far I
mean it points to a level of foreign
adventurism that I think it makes many
people in the region worried
I mean Saudi Arabia throughout its
history has spent tremendous amounts of
money on its military buys most of its
hardware from the United States and from
other countries including Britain it has
a massive massive military but it's
mostly chosen to keep things safe at
home and preferred historically to work
through quiet diplomacy through
deal-making through consensus through
things like that and so you know people
were pretty surprised that they decided
to get involved in this war in Yemen and
here we are you know more than two years
into it and Saudi Arabia doesn't have a
lot to show for itself it has made
progress in some areas but it's also
widely accused of bombing civilian areas
and destroying the Yemeni economy and
and there doesn't appear to be any end
in sight you know I've never
they've never Saudis that never
explained to me how they see themselves
getting out of this war in the near
future so you know this comes back to
Mohammed bin Salman because he's the
defense minister he's at the end of the
day the
in charge of these policies I think
domestically he's been able to protect
himself from some of this because inside
of the kingdom I think the royal family
has tremendous control over the
narrative that reaches its people they
have tremendous control over their media
alright does nuts yeah we're gonna leave
it there I'm afraid thanks very much for
joining us a thank you a night